[Music]
hello everyone welcome to any orangy CP
networking I'm sure Pinkett Anita and
I'm a product marketing manager here at
Google cloud I have with me Zack sales
who is a networking specialist customer
engineer and we are also thrilled to
have Nick Jake's joining us from one of
the leading u.s. US retailers target
Nick is a lead engineer at Target and
he'll be sharing with us how target uses
GCP with an emphasis on networking
products and services thank you so with
that let's get started we'll also leave
a few minutes of live Q&A in the end in
case your questions don't get answered
please feel free to use Dory in your
apps that will be open throughout the
week and we'll continue answering
questions over there and lastly these
conferences bring a big crowd all under
the same roof and we love to hear back
from you this session is an early series
so please spend a couple of minutes
giving us a survey in the end so that we
can continue to improve our content so
Newton gave us three laws of motion if
there were an equivalent three laws of
cloud networking would be one of those
because without the network there is no
cloud you might be wondering why am i
opening this session with this slide it
is because it's the emphasis on the
infrastructure that has let Google scale
the way we have which is depicted by our
own cloud services that you see here
eight different apps with a billion
users each one of the core
differentiators that acts as a
fundamental backbone of these apps is
our network and at GCP our goal has been
to give access to our customers to this
same network
now let's look at some of the global
infrastructure numbers around the world
which is very important for the customer
we have 19 regions that are live today
we will be launching new regions in
Jakarta Indonesia Osaka Japan and if you
saw the keynote this morning
sundar announced two more regions in
Seoul and Salt Lake City we also have
hundred and thirty-four pops or points
of presence these are the points where
the traffic is exchanged between
Google's network and the public Internet
it shouldn't come as a surprise we have
30 renewable energy project locations we
match 100% of the energy that we consume
with renewable energy to cut to maintain
our commitment to being carbon neutral
nine years ago Google became the first
major non telco to invest in subsea
cabals we have had 13 subsea cable
investment since then including to
private cables that were announced last
year so the key takeaway here is that
these numbers continue to grow between
what you saw last year and today and
these the infrastructure helps our
customers deliver their services closer
to their users now when you think about
the networking product portfolio there
are two elements I want you to think
about the first one is the
infrastructure that you just got a sneak
peak into and this is something that our
customers get by default when they move
to Google cloud the second piece is our
products and services that the customers
can consume there are over 20 products
in our portfolio not everything is shown
over here Zach and I will walk you
through the advancements that we have
made across these products which can be
broadly broken down into five pillars
Connect scale optimize secure and
modernize in the interest of time we
won't be able to cover the advancements
made in the last one year across all
each and every advancement but our take
our goal from this session is for you to
walk away with a fundamental
understanding of our products so that
then you can pick deep-dive sessions for
specific products that you are
interested in learning more over the
next two days so with that let's get
started with connect our goal here is to
ensure that we are enabling our
customers to connect to Google cloud on
their terms which means offering hybrid
connectivity options flexible hybrid
connectivity options we offer cloud
interconnect which comes in two flavors
dedicated interconnect and partner
interconnect if you can meet Google at
one of our eighty-one dedicated
interconnect locations you can opt for
that or if you cannot meet us there or
you prefer to work with a partner you
can opt for partner interconnect both
the options offer flexible bandwidth
between 50 Meg and 10 gig and
industry-leading SLA or four nines or
uptime we also offer cloud VPN for lower
bandwidth requirements and lower cost
both cloud interconnect and cloud VPN
are coming up with interesting
announcements tomorrow so stay tuned for
that the last option is peering which
you can also use to connect to Google
cloud now over the past one year we have
added several new partners for partner
interconnect so I'm sure you saw
something like this last year in this
session as well we continue to add more
partners to our ecosystem currently we
have over 50 partners that can help our
customers get on ramped to Google cloud
next on the connect pillar let's talk
about VPC first of all what is vp c vp c
stands for virtual private cloud it is
your own piece of logically isolated and
secure Google cloud it resembles the
traditional Network but with the
benefits of scalable infrastructure now
what's unique about our global VPC is
that it uses the same backbone that we
have built for our own products like
Google search YouTube that you saw
earlier and that enables our customers
to create VMs anywhere in the world
across any of our 19 regions and have
private connectivity between them by
default so the customers don't need to
set up any VPN connections or peering
connections or give their VMs external
eyepiece this reduces the toil of sprawl
and config and truly enables our
customers to have global access to their
workloads and that's what we mean when
we say 19 regions one VPC now on BBC we
have announced two key advancements in
the last one year the first one is
private access for GCP services this is
a new framework that provides private
connectivity between your VPC network
and the service that you're
communicating to cloud sequel is the
first GCP service to use this framework
the VM instances in your V PC network
and the network the service that you're
talking to communicate we are the
internal RFC 1918 IP addresses and once
you set up this connectivity any number
of GCP services can use that connection
so again to summarize it reduces these
be a toil of management and set up to
talk to GCP services
the second advancement that we have made
on the V PC side is the private Google
access for on-prem this enables your
on-prem hosts to reach Google API and
services through a cloud VPN tunnel or a
cloud interconnect connection so you can
leverage your existing private
connection to Google cloud for this and
that also means that you can take
advantage of VPC service controls that
Zak will cover later it does not require
your on-prem host to have external IP
addresses next on the connect pillar I
want to talk about a DD cloud ENS we
have added two capabilities on cloud DNS
in the last one year first one is
private zones and the second one is dns
forwarding private zones provides a
simple to manage internal DNS solution
for your private networks on GCP this
removes the basically the need to
provision and manage any additional
resources or compute resources
simplifying management for networking
administrators now as you can see in
this animation the DNS queries for
private zones my enterprise dot-com it
will just show up are restricted to your
internal network and any DNS queries for
that from the hostile agent on the right
from public internet get denied because
this is a private network now a key part
of a successful hybrid cloud strategy is
that you should be able to find your
resources easily whether they are on
Prem or on cloud DNS forwarding lets you
link your on-prem and cloud environments
easily you can set up bi-directional
forwarding zones between your on-prem
name servers and GCPs
internal name servers as you can see in
the animation on the outbound outbound
forwarding it lets your GCP resources
use your existing on-prem dns servers
and on the inbound forwarding it lets
your on-prem resources use a de Cloud
DNS to resolve domains with that we wrap
up the connect pillar and we are now
going to move to optimize vg8 network
service tiers last month some of you may
have seen that announcement come through
network service tiers let's our
customers customize the underlying
network
and basically optimize it for
performance or cost so if you are using
Google Cloud today you're most likely
using our premium tier Network the
premium tier delivers traffic over
Google's well provisioned low latency
highly reliable global network which we
saw earlier but for some T's cases
customers may prefer standard tier which
is a cheaper lower performance
alternative but it is still comparable
in performance to other public clouds
most cloud providers use what is called
hot potato routing which you see on the
bottom here which means when you try to
send traffic on their network
it gets offloaded to the public Internet
as soon as possible whereas we use cold
potato routing that you see on the top
we keep that traffic on Google's private
network for as long as possible and it
usually exits the public Internet as
close as possible to the end user
usually in the same city or town and
that enables us to provide better
reliability higher security and higher
performance said X is an Internet
performance monitoring and optimization
tools company which is now part of
Citrix did some performance comparisons
and as expected the premium tier is 1.7
x times faster than the standard tier so
on the top is the throughput from the
premium tier in green which is what you
get from our premium to your network and
on the bottom in the blue is the
standard to your throughput which is
what you get from our standard tier and
most other public clouds and you can get
these numbers online on siddik on the
website of Sid X's so that wraps up
optimized I would next like to move into
the scale pillar which includes cloud
load balancing and cloud Sirian before
we talk about the different advancements
that we have made in cloud load
balancing I would first like to talk
about how Google does global load
balancing load balancers and most other
public clouds are regional so that means
you have a single whip or virtual IP per
region and then you have back-end
instances in those regions as well
now regions are silos so the load
balancer in one region cannot use the
capacity of load balancer in another
whereas would Google global load
balancing you can have your application
instances running anywhere in the world
across any of our 19 regions but you get
a single whip or virtual IP to front-end
all those back-end instances so that way
the customers get full global capacity
and cross region failover
it's also closely tied to the autoscaler
that scales up or down your back-end
instances based on inline traffic so as
you can see this again helps our
customers deliver their services closer
to their end users and scale up or down
in line with traffic with that let's
take a look at some of the advancements
that we have made on our load balancers
we offer five different flavors of load
balancers and there are a lot of
capabilities that we have announced
across these these different flavors
over the last one year I won't have the
time to cover all of those there is a
deep dive session on our load balancers
tomorrow if you are interested in more
details I have just hand-picked a few
here on our internal load balancer we
now support all ports which basically
takes away the earlier requirement of
five ports very useful for users who
want to manage multiple layer four
applications also the internal load
balancer now reduces the these the
management and the conflicts set up by
supporting DNS based service discovery
on the HTTP load balancer front we now
support user-defined request headers
which basically insert client
information or the geolocation or the
RTD and then send it to the backend
instances and lastly in order to
continue our commitment of making the
internet faster on the HTTP load
balancer we support the quake and the
HTTP two protocols so if your
applications are latency sensitive they
are going to see a boost of performance
as a result of that integration on the
Google cloud CDN last year we went GA
with large object support allowing you
to cache and serve video and other
content up to five terabytes in size
so with that I talked about connect
optimize and scale pillars and I would
like to invite Zak to talk about secure
and modernize pillars next
thanks Rebecca let's jump right into the
secure pillar we have a number of key
advancements over the last 12 months
that I want to cover today so
historically when you want to store your
sensitive data inside of a Google cloud
managed service you had a set of
credentials that were tied to an iam
role that actually determined whether or
not a user could access that data so for
example if you're storing your data in
Google Cloud storage access control is
merrily dictated by which roles a
particular user or a set of credentials
have this could open up your
organization to some weaknesses for
example what if the I M roles are
misconfigured providing more access than
you intended what if those I M
credentials are compromised there may be
leaked publicly or somehow get into the
hands of somebody who's not supposed to
have them and lastly what if you have an
instance a virtual machine inside of
your environment that gets compromised
and somebody leverages that compromised
instance to try and exfiltrate data from
your V PC environment in addition to
this traditional network controls so
access lists that are restricting access
based on IP addresses and protocols
don't provide complete protection
because most Google services are exposed
from an accessibility perspective over
the same infrastructure leveraging the
same protocols as you've experienced
when you're accessing our API is across
a number of Google products it's almost
always TLS encrypted HTTP traffic so
just relying on the network controls
themselves didn't provide enough
protections and to solve this problem we
developed VPC service controls this is
now available it was released in the
last 12 months vpz service controls
provide you with the ability to actually
permit or deny had a perp on a per
project basis access to Google managed
service ap is based on the origin of the
request so this in combination with the
proper credentials and the network
access controls allow you to basically
define an explicit security perimeter
around your projects and networks inside
of Google cloud across which data cannot
transfer so for example if your intended
policy is that you want to create a
Google Cloud Storage bucket and store
your data in that bucket inside of our
project but you don't want to allow
access from the public Internet to that
but
bucket you can do that with VPC service
controls even if those users on the
internet have the right credentials so
vbc service control is very perfect very
powerful provide you with api level
controls to add the origin of the
request to the existing suite of
controls to control access to data that
you store inside of Google's managed
services next we have cloud armor cloud
armor allows you to protect your
internet facing load balanced workloads
inside of Google cloud this includes
protecting you from a variety of
distributed denial-of-service attacks
and this leverages the same protections
that Google has developed over the past
20 years to make sure that our own
services drive Gmail search etc remain
available and scalable on a global basis
cloud armor is integrated with Google
cloud load balancing and provides you
the ability to implement these controls
at the edge of Google's Network
so when shubik I talked about our global
backbone and leveraging our premium
network where your users come on to
Google's network as close to the user as
possible cloud armor allows you to
implement controls to determine from
both layer 7 all the way through
sorry layer 3 so traditional network
controls all the way through layer 7
what users are able to access your load
balanced workloads so cloud armor is
available now publicly as well next we
have cloud NAT this was probably one of
the most frequently requested
capabilities from customers and we've
made this available now in the last 12
months traditionally when you deploy
resources applications virtual machines
inside of the cloud you want to protect
those systems from direct access from
the public Internet
at the same time yep so cloud cloud net
solves this problem for you by
implementing a regional cloud NAT
gateway that allows you to control
access outbound access from those
virtual machines or your applications in
an efficient manner on a per region
basis there's a number of key benefits
to our cloud NAT implementation first
it's a completely software driven
distributed implementation so the actual
NAT capabilities are built into the
fabric of the VPC itself so there's no
device that you have to force traffic
through from an app perspective there's
no risk of potential choke points from a
performance
perspective because it's a completely
distributed system second we give you
the control over whether Google manages
the public IP addresses as you scale up
and down the number of translations that
need to happen for traffic destined to
the internet or whether you explicitly
define through static IP reservations
and your projects which public IP
addresses are associated with NAT the
latter case being very common for
example if you're establishing outbound
connections to partners and those
partners need to whitelist the source IP
addresses that you're coming from you
have a configuration choice there Google
can manage those addresses for you or
you can specify through static
reservations which public IP addresses
your services present themselves as on
the public internet and finally a single
cloud NAT gateway can support an entire
region regardless of scale so if you
have a hundred virtual machines in a
region if you have 15,000 virtual
machines in a region irrespective of the
number of VMs irrespective of the volume
of traffic that's going out towards the
internet from that particular region you
only need a single cloud NAT gateway and
again this goes back to the uniqueness
and the architecture and the distributed
way in which we implant these
capabilities so cloud NAT is the third
key capability and the secure pillar
that we want to talk about today next we
have two capabilities or sorry next we
have Google manage certificates so
Google has a history of leveraging TLS
encryption whenever possible if you
remember several years ago we actually
let the ability for websites who are
using HTTPS to improve their search
result rankings right so you're using
encrypted transport on the Internet
you're that actually influences search
page results at the same time we also
made the Chrome browser explicitly kind
of identify when websites were not using
TLS changing the standard expectation of
users to assume that all websites should
be using TLS encryption and visually
actually identifying when websites do
not really kind of changing the approach
there at the same time within cloud
we're constantly trying to make things
easier for customers to deploy and
manage and for this we have made
available in the last year Google
managed certificates so with Google
manage certificates when you create an
internet facing HTTPS load balancer as
part of that provisioning you can select
to have Google
automatically procure and configure the
certificate for the domains that are
supporting that particular load balance
or instance in addition this capability
automatically handles certificate
renewal when required and will
automatically revoke the certificates
when you delete the load balancer so
this now allows you to basically have
complete hands-off
TLS implementation for your internet
facing load balancers through Google
manage certificates in addition
regardless of how you host your backends
whether those are on compute instance
VMs or as or backed from a workload
perspective on kubernetes pods both
types are supported with this capability
so really making kind of the default
stance of TLS encrypted load balancing
very easy for you to manage and deploy
the next two capabilities fall under
kind of the area we consider to be
network to limitary and the first one is
called vbc flow logs so having
visibility obviously to traffic inside
of the cloud network is a common request
of customers this is something that I
think customers have kind of become
accustomed to in their on-premise
Network environments and so for traffic
that's traffic that's traversing your
VPC inside of Google Cloud whether it
stays solely within the VPC say between
different virtual machines inside of
Google Cloud or whether it's virtual
machines that are talking to resources
out on the public Internet you can now
enable VPC flow logs to get identifying
information about that traffic streamed
and distract sack driver from a
visibility perspective so if you have a
background in networking this is pretty
analogous to net flow from your on-prem
networking with some really great
additional features namely that not only
do we actually sample the traffic to
determine the traditional network
information from that traffic so source
and destination IP addresses what
protocols are used what ports we then
annotate that information with more I'll
say human friendly information so we add
the project information the actual
virtual machine instance names the VP
see that that instance is deployed in
and if the communication is actually
from an instance a virtual machine
inside of your VP C to the public
internet will actually annotate those
logs to tell you the geographic
information of what they're talking to
so you're talking to an endpoint that
may be in South Paulo Brazil as an
example so these annotations allow us to
basically to
at additional information that we know
about the flow to those flow records
this information is streamed natively by
default to stackdriver logging you can
also stream it into bigquery for
analytics or if you're using your own
on-premise or external logging analytics
capabilities you can actually stream the
logs to those through cloud pub/sub so
pretty powerful capability here in a
similar fashion we've also released in
the last 12 months logging for the VP's
native EPC firewall so you can now
enable on a per V PC firewall rule basis
the ability to enable logging so as
traffic comes through the V PC and
matches these firewall rules will
generate logs in a very similar manner
that we do for V PC flow logging so you
now have the ability from a compliance
perspective as an example to actually
prove to auditors that you're blocking
traffic that you say you're going to
block this is like V PC flow logs of
ativ available natively for streaming
into stackdriver logging again also with
bigquery or to external systems through
cloud pub/sub so two things with network
to eliminate e to give you better
visibility into the cloud network
environment for both traffic flowing
across your V PC but also for traffic
flowing through the native B PC firewall
so those those are some of the key
capabilities from a secure perspective
now moving on to modernize we're going
to talk specifically here about google
kubernetes engine and some stuff that
we're doing around sto so google
kubernetes engine if you're not familiar
is Google's managed instance of
kubernetes which is our production ready
solution for deploying containerized
applications over the past year we've
implemented a number of capabilities
that allow us to more tightly integrate
gke clusters with the best of cloud
native networking inside of google cloud
so the power that we have in terms of
global reach around our VP C's as well
as the native high-performance routing
that's now integrated directly into
google kubernetes engine and we do this
through something we call VPC native
clusters which basically takes the
networking that is typically implemented
as an overlay inside of kubernetes and
actually makes that a fundamental part
of the underlying VPC network so this is
good not only from a visibility and from
a routing perspective because we now for
example treat pods and services the SE
way we treat virtual machines from a
reach ability perspective but it also
improves the security where we have
strong kind of anti-spoofing measures
that are deployed inside of the network
that are natively integrated inside of
gke this provides additional
capabilities when we look at integrating
networking into your on-premise
environments or hybrid and networking
because again capabilities that are
enabled as part of your VPC from a
routing and visibility perspective are
also now available for your kubernetes
clusters so very powerful capabilities
with respect to gke also for gke we've
released something called container
native load balancing this is currently
in beta so in the past when a load
balancer like an external load balancer
like our Google Cloud load balancer it's
targeted resources inside of a
kubernetes cluster you'd have a
situation somewhat similar to this right
you have multiple nodes inside of your
kubernetes cluster the load balancer
actually targets the nodes or the
virtual machine instances as the
backends for those for the load balancer
now on those nodes you may have a
disproportionate number of pods and
kubernetes you could even have a
situation where some of those not nodes
don't actually have the pods that you're
targeting from the load balancing
perspective scheduled on that node and
in that case IP tables or cube proxy on
those kubernetes nodes was responsible
for a second level of load balancing so
the external load balancer gets the
traffic to the node IP tables or cube
proxy inside of kubernetes is
responsible for them getting the traffic
to the direct pod that you're trying to
communicate with this is commonly known
in the kubernetes community as a double
hop problem you basically have two
layers of load balancing this is
especially problematic if you look at
something like a regional kubernetes
cluster where you have the actual nodes
for the gke cluster spread across
multiple zones inside the region the
external load balancer could send that
traffic to a node in zone a as an
example and iptables in that node in
zone a could then decide it's gonna
actually load balance that traffic to a
pod that's running on a node inside of
zone B or C or D right so that second
level of load balancing can add not only
higher latency but for a regional
cluster it can add additional costs
because you're paying for the traffic
that goes between the
zones inside of a region so now with
container native load balancing we've
internet we've introduced something
called Network endpoint groups and
essentially here what we're doing is
we're allowing the pods to basically
behave as if they're virtual machines
from a networking perspective inside of
the V PC so instead of the kubernetes
nodes actually being the target of the
load balancer it's in fact the pods
themselves that are the direct target of
the external load balancer so when
traffic comes in from your users to our
external load balancer the load balancer
looks at not the backends from a node
perspective inside of kubernetes it
actually seen as the traffic directly to
the kubernetes pods themselves so you
remove essentially the second hop of
load balancing
this improves latency and can actually
reduce costs for traffic going between
zones inside of a regional cluster so
container native load balancing very
powerful as well also for gke we've
actually provided the ability now to
integrate the load balancing
capabilities in gke with some of our
cloud native capabilities particularly
with our content delivery network cloud
CDN identity aware proxy I a P and cloud
armor which I talked about a few slides
ago now you can configure and Clun
configure and tune these capabilities
directly from within kubernetes
manifests or configuration files and the
way we do this is with a concept called
back-end config you've used back in
config to configure these native
services so CDN I ap cloud armor etc
independent of kubernetes ingress which
defines a web based load balancer or
services so you don't have to keep
overloading the existing kubernetes
constructs with annotation and other
things that need to be approved by the
broader kubernetes community to
integrate with Google Cloud native
capabilities so with back-end config you
now have the ability to specify
independently of ingress and services
integration with these native Google
cloud services and then you pair those
two things together so for example an
external web based load balancer that
you may establish you may instantiate it
as a kubernetes ingress can now also
integrate natively with cloud CDN can
now also integrate natively with a
and can now also integrate natively with
cloud armor so very powerful
capabilities from a kubernetes
perspective now moving on to Sto so if
you haven't heard about sto which I
imagine most of you have SEO is an open
source service mesh it's heavily
inspired by a lot of internal systems at
Google but it is developed in
collaboration with a number of external
partners including IBM and lyft the ride
sharing company from a open source
perspective it essentially provides a
way for you to build a service mesh
between your different micro-services
that includes load balancing it includes
very fine-grained
telemetry and monitoring capabilities
and also allows you to implement service
to service network based authentication
so mutual TLS authentication and allows
you to do all of these things
transparently without making any code
changes directly to your application
code so it essentially provides an
ability for you to abstract away all of
these common capabilities in the cloud
environment without having to
repetitively implement these in terms of
your application code now what we've
released in the last year is you can now
with a single click or a single flag in
the CLI you can actually provision sto
as an add-on for your gke clusters when
you do this what happens is we
automatically deploy the sto control
plane the SEO control plane is made up
of a number of services pilot which
handles the actual traffic policies for
which traffic goes where mixer which
handles telemetry the visibility we
talked about and policy controls and
Citadel which handles automatic
certificate provisioning and revocation
all these together are deployed in your
gke cluster and not only are they
deployed with one click but for the
ongoing upgrade life of those control
plane services we automatically handle
the upgrades for those as well this
again is part of the add-on capabilities
with GK and with that I'd like to
welcome up Nik Jakes from Target to talk
about how Target is leveraging some of
these capabilities
[Applause]
right thanks Zack
really glad to be here my name is Nick
Jakes I am a lead engineer at Target and
I work on our cloud platform team my
team is responsible for building
managing and operating the
infrastructure and the platform that our
application teams a target deploy on top
of so if you're not familiar with target
just a brief refresher we're a
nationwide retailer we have over 1,800
stores at last count I think it's 1845
39 distribution centers and over 350,000
team members we have headquarters
locations across the US but notably in
Minneapolis and in the bay area here and
we currently rank number 39 on the
fortune 500 in addition to all of our
stores and physical locations we have
target comm and our mobile apps now in
terms of virtual square-feet target.com
is our biggest store
it's visited by a hundred million guests
per month and is currently the fourth
most visited retail site in the US when
people think target a lot of people tend
to think of traditional brick-and-mortar
retail however in the last few years
we've really become a technology company
that enables our retail presence both
online and in-store
and so I'm really excited to share some
of that technology that we're using and
we put into place with you today where I
want to start is what target runs on GCP
now when we talk about our website
there's a really big component to it
that we refer to as non commerce and
this basically is about 73% of our GCP
footprint non commerce is browsing
searching looking at product information
images reviews and activities of that
nature we then have commerce now
commerce as a name implies is adding
items to your cart checking out using a
payment method like a credit card and so
on
this represents about 27% of our total
footprint and GCP and this is a segment
that is subject to regulatory compliance
social security is extremely important
here we also have our developer portal
hosted on GCP so this is where we host
documentation for our API s as well as
self-service mechanisms to renew your
API
and things of that nature and we host
static content so think of JavaScript
and images and things like that
that we can put in GCS and host there
and not need to run compute in order to
present that to our guests next what I
want to do is just run you through some
very very high-level architecture of how
we're deployed in GCP and how things
work so this is our non commerce
architecture we migrated this into GCP
and 2017 from another cloud provider the
entire point of this environment is it's
a general-purpose general tenancy
environment and we use a model that
Google refers to as standalone VPC so we
have three of these large monolithic
projects they're broken up her
environment we have a lab project an on
project in a production project and
where I'll start with this if you take a
look in the lower right hand corner is
our data center connectivity today we
use cloud VPN to attach our data centers
to GCP and specifically to a set of
subnets that we refer to as platform
services in our platform services subnet
we operate as the name somewhat implies
services that are common across all of
the cloud providers that we operate in
so for example we operate service
discovery secrets management data
persistence through Cassandra and
Message Queuing via Kafka these services
can communicate directly with our data
center for replication purposes up next
we have our application hosting
environment which is on top now again
this is a general tenancy environment
but what's interesting here is this is
non-routable to our data centers
so if our applications need to
communicate with our data centers they
actually do so indirectly through the
platform services that we provide to
them the interesting piece of this is
this means our application hosting
subnets are air-gap from our data
centers so that's a little advantageous
in terms of security finally in the
upper-right what happens when we have
calls that come in from the internet
they actually traverse our CDN provider
and then go to the appropriate load
balancer now next up is our commerce
architecture we migrated this in 2018
last summer and we migrated this from a
Colo facility this environment has one
prime
a purpose and that is to host regulate
workloads that are subject to regulatory
compliance or have high data security
classifications this requires really
strong isolation and segmentation
between everything that runs up there as
I change slides you might have noticed a
subtle but very very important
difference and that is we're using
shared VPC in this environment
so I mentioned non commerce uses three
monolithic projects in commerce we
actually use 56 projects across all of
our environments to construct our
architecture mm-hmm what we've done is
we've partitioned out all of our
applications and all of our platform
services into their own individual
subnets with their own individual
service projects for data center
connectivity we're now currently using
partner interconnect and in another
interesting divergence here are our
applications can connect directly to our
data center workloads this is
particularly important because we run
some applications that need to have
synchronous callbacks to our data
centers in order to complete things like
transactions when you're checking out
otherwise beyond all the segmentation
the platform services that we operate
are the same and the applications that
we host are generally operating in the
same way we use compute engine and we
use HTTP load balancers our ingress
traffic comes through a CDN just like on
Commerce so let's look at a few common
pieces the first one that I want to
touch on is the fact that we use layer 7
HTTP load balancers in almost all cases
in fact in over 99% of our load balance
or use cases we use these we use cloud
armor and SSL policies which I which
I'll touch on a little bit later to
secure our edge in our platform services
environment we operate proxies and Nats
now this is important because our
instances by and large don't have public
IP addresses but we need a way for these
instances to reach out to the Internet
to hit third-party api's to do things
like address validation for example so
we operate proxies and Nats and we
install inspection software that can
police traffic on these and we emit
those logs to our on-premise sims for
analysis we use firewall rules in all of
our environments but we take an
interesting approach with these in our
commerce environment we use a company
use firewall rules that are based on
service accounts as both sources and
targets and this helps us achieve the
level of micro segmentation when it
comes to network connectivity that's
allowed we use private connectivity in
all of our scenarios and I'll touch on
specifics about private connectivity a
little later on we use stackdriver
logging and monitoring pretty heavily
cloud DNS for both public and private
authoritative record resolution and we
use cloud pub/sub as a way to move
traffic between GCP and our on-premise
data centers so I went through all of
that to give you a little context for
these next few items that I want to
discuss with you the first one is V PC
service controls now Zac already went
through a lot of the fine details of EBC
service controls so I'm just gonna talk
to you about a target use case for you
what you see on the screen is a grouping
of our Commerce projects and you also
see some of our non commerce projects
now we basically have dozens of projects
and these have varying different levels
of data security classifications they
also may have varying levels of
regulatory compliance that are required
what we don't want to do in these
situations are cross logical boundaries
but the problem is earlier on last year
these were more imaginary boundaries
defined by target policy and not
anything concrete so for example if you
had the appropriate service account
credentials you could for example reach
from our commerce environment into our
non commerce environment look at some
stuff that's in the storage there or
vice versa
now we don't allow this by policy but
there isn't an actual way to prevent
this so what can we do to prevent this
type of activity well we can use V PC
service controls and we can draw a
perimeter around the projects that all
have the same data classification so in
this example we draw this around our
commerce projects what we do then is we
disable API access that crosses this
perimeter so this denies the access
across the perimeter both inside and out
and helps us prevent crossing between
different data classifications there's
another really big benefit here and that
is what happens if a third party
suddenly becomes involved
and you're worried about data
exfiltration now this is basically a
nightmare scenario for you um you don't
want people to exfiltrate data and the
problem is once data has been
exfiltrated you really can't put the
genie back into the bottle so data
breaches and data loss are a huge
concern and you don't want to lose the
trust of your customers thankfully VPC
service controls also applies to this
particular scenario so exfiltration
attempts can be blocked so just some key
takeaways here the VPC service controls
basically helps prevent forms of an
authorized data movement and that
applies regardless of if you control the
projects or not the key here is this
helps you prevent that activity from
occurring in the first place now at
Target we have ways to detect data
exfiltration but once you detect that
data has been exfiltrated it's a little
too late
so with a combination of VPC service
controls and our detective methods we
feel really comfortable with our
security posture and the great part is
this works regardless of who or what is
trying to move this data so whether
you're trying to do it on purpose or
maybe take a little shortcut at work
because you're about to approach a
deadline it'll still work next I want to
talk to you about the interconnect
options that we use now I'm gonna start
with cloud VPN because when we migrated
to GCP in 2017 cloud VPN was the first
interconnect mechanism that we've used
so we've been using it for over two
years now now the great part about cloud
VPN is it's relatively inexpensive it's
pretty quick to set up and it can scale
to some pretty reasonable performance
there are some drawbacks if you have
really high throughput needs or if you
have extremely high demands for
reliability but by and large it works
great now importantly VPN will typically
traverse the public Internet and that
means that there can be some issues that
will impact your VPN connectivity so for
example let's say that the red provider
here has some sort of issue with their
edge and their routes are withdrawn
now this can cause a bit of temporary
connectivity issues if your traffic was
passed over the red provider you can
also have issues upstream or downstream
with capacity because the provider
withdrew their routes and finally
there's a
oh that occurs sometimes a little too
often and these are route hijacks now
these don't necessarily have to be
malicious but they can still impact the
stability of your VPN tools so all said
cloud VPN actually works pretty well for
us in non commerce because we don't have
any synchronous requirements however we
do need to have higher availability in
the commerce environment and that is
because we have synchronous callbacks to
our data centers any interruptions in
those callbacks prevents checkout from
working properly which impacts our
revenue so we wanted to explore a
different solution we move to partner
interconnect and what we do here is we
operate a router at our edge our router
connects to an ISP who happens to be one
of the partner interconnect providers
and we have a private redundant path
that avoids the internet and meets back
up with Google at its peering edge and
goes into the V PC so this is really
helpful in terms of maintaining a very
very high stability environment for
critical connectivity as chewbacca
mention is scalable as well so you can
scale between 50 megabits per second to
10 gigabits per second and if you're
looking to provision things really
quickly and you have high bandwidth
needs you can actually provision this a
little quicker than direct interconnect
in some cases now just briefly I want to
talk about cloud armor and what I have
here on the screen is an example flow
from our guests calling all the way into
some resources that we have in GCP so
what happens here is our guest will call
to one of our digital properties and
that call will go through our CDN fastly
what will happen here is will traverse
the CDN there's a number of things that
happen here
web application firewalls are laughs
routing caching and so on and eventually
that request will make it down to our
load balancers through cloud armor and
into the backend instance once that
traffic's there we'll generate a
response and I'll go all the way back
out to our guest now the reason this
works is we've configured cloud armor to
allow traffic in from fastly and a few
other approved sources our guest though
aren't aren't the only thing that are
out there on the Internet so you can
imagine there's some malicious actors
out there running port scanners and
various other Economist
things and we don't actually want them
to hit our services and they really
don't need to in the first place
in fact we only want fastly our CDN our
data centers and our headquarters
locations to be able to hit these load
balancers so when they send traffic it
hits the load balancer and we're
actually able to see this it's logged in
stack driver but the traffic is blocked
by a cloud our policy and those requests
never make it to the backend instances
in either case we see these logs and we
can export them to our sim for security
analysis all right next up really
quickly I just want to talk about our
use cases for VPC flow logs and firewall
logs Zak did a great job running through
these there's a lot of you know rich
annotations and metadata that you get
with these but what I thought I'd do is
show you a sanitized firewall log
example in case you haven't seen one of
these before
and just talk through it a little bit so
what we can see in this particular
example is we have an instance that's
running in a service project and it
seems to be a little suspicious and
notably what we can see happening here
is this instance is connecting to an IP
address that's not on the public
Internet and it's using protocol 17 in
port 53 so this is UDP 53 DNS now in
situations like this DNS could be used
as a command and control mechanism for a
botnet for example so this isn't really
great now the good news is we've
actually blocked this traffic with an
explicit eat rest and I all rule that
we've set it a really low priority so we
have some other rules that mandate
having an allow rule in place before
that traffic and egress so we're
protected here but it's really helpful
to know this we take this information
and we used cloud pub/sub to send it to
our on-prem sim for analysis and
alerting we also can use other sinks and
exports like bigquery or GCS and we
actually export these to GCS as well for
long term retention and in case we need
to do any sort of forensic analysis so
looking forward really quickly I just
want to run through a couple of things
over the next year targets really
looking forward to some enhancements
with VPC service controls there's a
piece that we didn't touch on yet called
restricted Google API is
it's a slash 30 net block now the real
advantage to using this beyond being
able to restrict what ap is you can
actually talk to is it's a slash 30 net
block so it's a much smaller address
space to manage than the 19 net blocks
that represent Google's public API s so
it ultimately results in a reduction in
firewall rules and routes and other
various management overhead cloud nap
now managing naps is toilsome we do it
and they can be difficult to scale so
we're really looking forward to cloud
nap but today we install software on our
nats that inspects traffic and that
isn't available yet in cloud nat so
we're looking forward to some potential
developments there and then finally
Google's managed TLS certificates target
operates over 200 HTTPS load balancers
and that is a lot of certificates to
keep track of so we're gonna have some
discussions with our internal security
teams later this year and see if we can
move to these now before I we move to QA
I just wanted to give a shameless plug a
colleague Nicole and I will be giving a
presentation tomorrow that discusses a
little more in detail some of the
architectures specifically around shared
VPC vbc peering and firewall rules that
involve service accounts so if you're
interested in seeing this in a little
more detail please join us tomorrow it
should be a lot of fun and I know that
conferences are busy so we're gonna do
Q&A in a little bit here if you have any
target specific questions and you need
to run to your next session this email
address will be active for the next
couple weeks so feel free to shoot me an
email address or shoot me an email and
I'll try to answer it as best I can and
with that I'll hand things back over to
Shuba cutter wrap things up thank you
[Applause]
[Music]